all right gregory
gregory where'd you grow up where are
you from originally uh new bedford
massachusetts
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents um
yeah
my dad was a fisherman
my mom was a stay-at-home mom when i was
a young child uh
he uh
wasn't around much because he was always
out fishing you know
and uh he had an alcohol problem
and uh
so i grew up mostly with my mom
and i had a little brother and a little
sister
how would you describe your childhood um
bleak
yeah i didn't i didn't really
think too much of life from an early age
i pretty much found the world kind of
horrifying
and uh the people in it what kind of
stuff was going on at home that would
make you see it as bleak um i well i
found out later
my mom uh always resented me because
that was the reason she had to get
married to my dad
you know i didn't i didn't learn that
until later on in life
so
um that always manifested itself in in
different ways you know
um
just her
you know i was like that was a pretty
good kid you know i was pretty well
behaved kid and stuff you know but i was
still always getting you know
it wasn't necessarily always physical
violence but i spent most of my you know
childhood it seems like locked up in my
room with something you know and
and not being able to go out and do
stuff or watch tv or anything like that
you know and
i don't know i thought that was you know
i didn't realize how abnormal that was
you know i just thought
i don't know what i thought of it
um but yeah it was bleak
what kind of kid were you in high school
um
um
my grades started slipping in high
school
uh since when i started experimenting
with drugs and alcohol and stuff like
that actually junior high started
um but like i ran track i was real good
at that you know but i was my my parents
made me quit that after a season or two
because my grades weren't good enough
um
so i guess they figured i need more time
just to study at home or whatever
uh did that work no
no it didn't work
um
and uh
yeah i started i was doing coke and
stuff in high school like that but like
i always had a love for opiates and i
remember i broke my arm when i was 11
years old and i was prescribed percocet
for it
and uh i'd take maybe half a pill at a
time whatever doctor said no
that was like
you know a relief from the it was like
the opposite of pain you know
um and i uh i think that's what
governments
do for a person what do they make you
feel especially when you have like
trauma all your aches and pains go away
um but mentally it dulls your emotions
um you get a sense of euphoria yeah
you know things are going to be okay you
know if things are okay don't seem as
bad you know but while you're while the
high's lasting
um
you know but then if you don't you
didn't you know at a certain point
you need it just to function you know
and you stop getting really
feeling any
positive effects from it you're just
again trying to get well you know trying
to get
you know not sick anymore you know and
that's uh
the only real replacement for that is
either a great childhood or lots of
therapy it seems yeah probably so yeah
and then after school where'd you go
from there did you graduate yes i did
and i went i i started working on
fishing boats but somewhere before my
senior year
and then uh
when i graduated my dad and i went down
to
louisiana
and uh
got a job on a boat this people we knew
bought a
a boat from dow chemical a rig tending
boat and we converted it into a fishing
boat and brought up to alaska and worked
on that
um for a while and then so you fished in
louisiana no we didn't fish there we
just bought they purchased the boat
there and we
did some work on our deal and brought it
up to washington state and um had
hydraulics put on and then went up to
alaska where they and worked the scallop
industry fishery how was that alaska it
was it was beautiful
um i liked it
i was making a lot of money especially
if such a young kid you know louisiana
is beautiful too yeah it is i didn't
care for the weather too much down there
that's awfully humid yeah
um i ask it's
it is but we were in dutch habit it
really doesn't get that cold there it
snows a lot
but it's um it's in the aleutian island
chain and it's kind of almost like a
subtropical
climate really you know
alaska yeah it doesn't get super cold it
just but it does snow and rain a lot you
know
and you get a lot of bad storms and like
that but
well it gets
on in alaska it's really cold inland
more than on the coast you know
so tell me about drugs and fishing um
there was a lot of drugs around they
seemed to go around yeah but back home
in bedford there was a lot of heroin and
stuff in the fishing fleet and and uh
the old the older guys mostly drank
but uh most of the youngsters did heroin
and cocaine and stuff like that
but it was easy it wasn't you know you
could kind of maintain because
you'd be gone for two weeks and then
home for like five days so you you know
you couldn't get much of a habit really
you know so i was able to
to still maintain and have an apartment
and stuff like that and not uh
like be having to commit crimes or
anything or be on the street you know
for a while
money is good right yeah it is but it's
not guaranteed you know
like
you know there were some months i've
probably made
fifteen thousand dollars but then
there's um months i made maybe a couple
hundred bucks you know if the boat broke
down or in the winter time it's if the
weather's bad you can't fish you know
what i mean
so it's it's it's it can be good but
it's not guaranteed you know
do you have kids i have one son
you're married or no
no
i i was married my wife passed away
though
but she's not who i had the child with
oh i think
and did you raise your son
no um
i never never met him uh
she
his mom uh gave birth to him while i was
in prison in california
and uh
she gave him up for adoption and so i've
never been in his life or anything like
that
were you in prison for
oh um in california i was in prison for
a criminal threat
i got into an argument with a security
guard at a um
at a store and he said that i guess i
threatened him and uh
and made him feel in fear of his life so
they gave me um he gave me a strike in
uh two years with half
that was the second time i've been to
prison
the first time i got arrested i went to
prison for five years back in
massachusetts
that was for
stolen car in a firearm charging an
armed robbery charge
were these like drug related
absolutely yeah convictions
yeah everything i would
the time i ever broke the law was around
to
the procurement of drugs you know
drugs kind of been a constant in your
life since yeah you discover them yeah
definitely there's been years
years when i've been on heroin but then
i was just i was be beyond meth and
drinking every day you know so it was
always something
[Music]
how long have you been down here on skid
row
um
i'm not really on skid row i'm mostly
hanging around
in k-town and stuff like that but uh but
you're homeless yeah i've been homeless
off and on since i've been in california
it's good road is kind of expanding and
spreading out to like macarthur park and
koreatown
yeah it is it is
it's all over the city
[Music]
i was living in echo park for a while
with defense set off echo park in santa
monica and venice yeah it's everywhere
really yeah
what's it like living in a tent
i don't know i don't even i don't have a
tent i just oh you just wing it yeah i
don't even own a blanket
and i just uh
dozed off here and they were like i
sleep on the bus a lot on the train you
know right
um
[Music]
and the purpose for that is just people
will leave you alone yeah no you know
you you know you will get robbed not get
robbed yeah because i've been i had
myself stolen i was sleeping so many
times
a couple weeks ago i was down on sixth
in maine
and uh
i had two backpacks with me i sent them
off to the side i was sitting i was kind
of strawberries and stuff making
breakfast
and uh someone came up to me and based
me in the face and tried hitting me with
a pipe and i got up and ran and they
took my backpacks
and
huh good morning i know you could have
just said kick in the backpacks i
probably given it to them you know they
got they got a bunch of dirty laundry is
what he got
there's a pair of ray-bans in one of
them but that was just by chance
i don't know if he thought i wasn't
homeless so i had money or something but
uh
yeah that sucked
i'm glad i'm lucky though because the
person who did it he he hit a couple
people
during the course that week put a couple
of people in the hospital after making
them and hitting with the pipe so i was
lucky as soon as he sprayed me i got up
and ran
and uh there was a couple people i knew
around there they got me milk and stuff
like that to try and you know
mitigate it somewhat milk helps with
mace a little bit yeah
yeah yogurt's supposed to be the best so
yeah being master's got to sub
yeah luckily none went in my mouth um
but it just went in my eyes you know so
i couldn't see for a while yeah and it
burns
what emotions do you go through living
this life
um
being here
sometimes
i don't really feel
i don't i mean i don't like being
homeless but it doesn't
[Music]
it doesn't um
it maybe it doesn't bother me as much as
it should you know
um
because
i don't know i mean people have i know
those people that have it works you know
probably people who have houses that
have it worse than me you know because
my life's not that bad really you know i
mean i got some decent friends and stuff
like that and
you know
uh are you unhappy
um
sometimes
but not not in general i don't think so
no you know
uh
i mean i mean i'm as happy as i've ever
been you know
you know i just it is what it is you
know it's uh
it's not how i m how i would choose to
live if i had a choice if i if i was
able to you know do something different
um
[Music]
i uh
i sure would you know but um
you know i you know i don't know i get
you know i
spend
probably about 150 bucks a day on drugs
and how do you generate 150 bucks
shoplift
[Music]
there's a lot of that going on yeah i
know i know like every every
male that i interviewed is doing it yeah
it's going to come to a screeching halt
pretty soon though i think with this all
the new technology that you know they
have now for facial recognition and all
that stuff and
um
what will male drug addicts resort to
i'm wondering
i guess the same thing female targets
resorts
yeah well yeah there seems to be a
market for it yeah but i mean maybe for
the youngsters i don't know what i'm
gonna do though
um
[Music]
i don't know maybe it'll be time to get
clean you know
what's your biggest regret
um
my biggest regret
probably not not not being around my for
my family and stuff like that and
you talk to them at all
not very often no
yeah do they know the situation you're
in now yeah yeah
you know i don't know if you know the
extent of it you know but you know i'm
on the streets and stuff like that and
uh
yeah and i have my i had my little
sister died when i was in prison i felt
bad i wasn't around you know for that
uh
but going back to fishing where you can
still maybe do the drugs sometimes
but it might be a healthier life than
this yeah i don't know if i could now at
this
you know i got um herniated discs in my
back and stuff because it's really
physical demanding physically yeah
so
52 52
um i mean i was i i missed it i missed
it was a pretty good
pretty good life you know
uh because you'd get you know you you
work for a few weeks and you get five
days off in a row you know so i always
thought that was cool about it
and uh sometimes you make a lot of money
sometimes you don't
just depends
it's a certain type of character that
does that kind of work isn't it not
every guy can do it no probably not
some people get seasick because some
people get scared
yeah and uh
it's real tedious work too
especially uh in the scallop industry
because
you catch them then you have to cut them
all cut the meats out of all them and
stuff like that you know so it's almost
like a it's a grind you know you catch a
lot of rocks and stuff too you gotta get
rid of those every time you
haul back your gear you know
but like my whole
dad side of my family just about was
involved in it at one time you know
all my uncles and cousins and stuff like
that
you've been in love before
huh have you been involved before in
love yeah yeah i think so
yeah
at least once yeah
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
the most important thing i've learned
to try and have um
[Music]
try and maintain your you know some kind
of moral code and stuff like that and
stick to it and in spite of what
not used you know being an actress and
excuse to be a piece of [ __ ] and and
just [ __ ] everybody over and you know
um
[Music]
you know just because you you have a
drug problem doesn't mean you have to be
a bad person you know you can still
you know have some morals yeah i mean
you can't be 100 there for anybody you
know because drugs is is is your main
priority but you don't have to be you
don't have to be a piece of [ __ ] and for
you to hang on to some morals is
is commendable i mean i think i got a
pretty good name out here on the streets
so yeah now that not everyone can
maintain a no a moral code
yeah
all right gregory thank you so much for
sharing your story all right that's it
that's it
i wish you the best of luck your name is
mark okay
you